Israeli leader Benjamin Netanyahu
appears headed for an historic fifth
term the Prime Minister holds a slim
lead over his main rival after a tight
election battle his apparent victory
comes despite impending corruption
charges Netanyahu put his close
relationship with President Trump and
other world leaders at the center of his
campaign now he's set to become the
longest-serving Prime Minister in
Israel's 71 year history Seth Doane is
in tel-aviv Seth good morning good
morning most of the votes have been
counted and at this point
Israel's two main parties are virtually
tied for the number of seats that they
have in parliament and last night both
of them actually declared victory we
were at blue and white party
headquarters of Benny Ganz's Ganz took
to the stage and called himself Israel's
next prime minister but then not long
after Benjamin Netanyahu took to the
stage at his party headquarters and said
that he was declaring victory he had
fireworks and all but here's the thing
neither of these parties have enough
seats in parliament to create a
government on their own so the tough
part now begins a coalition must be
formed and at this point it appears that
Benjamin Netanyahu's Likud Party has the
pathway to do that he would rely on
support from far-right parties and also
from ultra-orthodox religious parties to
create that government and this further
push to the right this swing to the
right here in Israel would not only have
an apat impact on local domestic
policies but also world affairs and
certainly a path to peace here in the
Middle East and Palestinians have
already expressed concerns over that
last minute campaign pledge made by
Benjamin Netanyahu to annex settlements
in the West Bank that is of course quite
controversial because that land is seen
by most of the world as occupied
territory Nora all right more there Seth
in is Tel Aviv Israel thank you